[Music]
there's a
land that i heard of
once in a lullaby ariana
[Music]
opera singer marissa bettos shocks the
america's got talent judges with an
impressive audition she's so good she
may have the queen of impressions ariana
grande beat it was like so crazy
in a sneak peek of tuesday's agt 23 year
old marissa takes the stage starting off
singing an opera version of somewhere
over the rainbow
[Music]
then that's when things get interesting
she gives judge heidi klumabox to call
out names of marissa's favorite
impressions and this happens
[Applause]
[Music]
yep that's marissa delivering a spot on
stevie mix impression that was kind of a
great thing and there's more iconic
singers she can mimic
[Applause]
[Music]
call us stunned but let's hear her
imitate ariana grande one more time or
should we say last time
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
marissa receives a standing ovation from
all of the judges but she seems to
really wow simon cowell
we knew this season would be a hit at
least that's what howie mandel teased to
e.t back in may this year
i mean it is off the hook people
it's not normal people are thinking like
outside the box they really are
nothing seems normal and fellow judge
sofia vergara agrees she told us the
season 17 contestants are next level i
had been very impressed already this
season yeah it's been you know
such an amazing
amount of talented people we will have
to wait and see if those opera pipes
advance marissa to the live show but we
have a feeling she won the judges over
with her celeb impressions hopefully
it's enough to get her a golden buzzer
we have an extra golden buzzer that we
had last season though
and that was that is amazing because
sometimes we feel that there's it's not
fair that we don't have more of them
because everyone is getting so good
[Music]
me